[موسيقى]
هل يمكنك من فضلك أن تعطينا
فكرة عامة عما
تحاول الإدارة تحقيقه في الشرق الأوسط
على سبيل المثال هل ما
زالت الإدارة تعتبر السعوديين
والإسرائيليين حلفاء مهمين
أه حسنًا أه تعرف مرة أخرى أعتقد أننا
أه هناك  العمليات الجارية
والعمليات الداخلية المشتركة بين الوكالات
التي أعتقد أنها أكدت اجتماعًا مشتركًا بين الوكالات
الأسبوع الماضي فقط لمناقشة
مجموعة من القضايا في الشرق الأوسط
حيث كنا هنا فقط ثلاثة أسابيع
ونصف وأعتقد أنني سأسمح  هذه
العمليات السياسية ترى نفسها
قبل أن نقدم نوعًا من
التخطيط الكامل لما
ستكون منهجيات الأمن القومي لدينا في مجموعة
من القضايا
[موسيقى
] أريد أن أسألك عن مكالمات القادة الأجانب
واحدة من القضايا المتبقية هي
رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي  الوزير
بنيامين ونتنياهو أه سفير الأمم المتحدة
نشر تغريدة أمس عبرت فيها
عن إحباط من أن المكالمة لم
تحدث بالفعل
فهل يمكنك إخبارنا من البيت الأبيض
يتطلع الرئيس إلى التحدث مع
رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو
من الواضح أنه شخص لديه علاقة
طويلة الأمد معه
ومن الواضح أن هناك
علاقة مهمة تربطه
بالولايات المتحدة  إسرائيل على
الجبهة الأمنية
وكشريك رئيسي في المنطقة ، لكنه
سيتحدث معه قريبًا ، ليس لدي
تاريخ أو وقت محدد لك في تلك
المكالمة حتى الآن